Cái này hơi to nhỉ.
Con tà điện to quá.
Ok.
Xin chào tất cả các bạn.
Ừ. Đợi mình tí đang ở đây đang hơi ổn.
Ok. Xin chào tất cả các bạn.
Cho dù hiện tại đang không có ai cả vì
mình cũng ơ có tận bảy người này. Sao
đây không người nhỉ?
Ờ
xin chào các bạn. Các bạn nghe thấy mình
không ạ?
Mà dù giả sử không có ai thì mình cũng
không nhiên lắm vì mình cũng có thông
báo gì đâu. Đương nhiên mình xuất hiện
mà. Thì à
mình thấy vô tình
mình kiểu thấy vụ Can you hear me
clearly? H sao cái của mình lại tự động
dịch sang tiếng Anh mất rồi này.
Nghe rõ ạ. Nhưng mà câu đấy lại là từ
tiếng Anh. Can you hear me click? Vãi
chưởng. Nó tự động dịch cái chat của
mình.
Để mình chỉnh sao tự động dịch chat nhỉ?
Hỏi thật đấy.
Xem
analic
stream.
Tại sao nó tự động dịch chat của mình
nhỉ?
Nó cũng hay đấy nhưng mà
ừ
thế nào nhỉ?
Mình có cần đâu.
Chẳng lẽ mình đang để chế độ tiếng Anh
nên thành ra nó tự động dịch hết chat
phần chat ạ.
Ok không sao
thì à tí là xin chào các bạn lâu lắm rồi
mình mới quay trở lại. À mình cũng sẽ cố
đây rồi. Hello thầy. Ok bây giờ nó kiểu
nó cứ tự động dịch chắc của tôi là ví dụ
here I am hello teacher. Đấy. À mình
thực ra là để mà có video ngày hôm nay
đó là nhờ phải cũng phải nhiều yếu tố
phải ít nhất là ba yếu tố đấy. bột là
hôm qua mình trong kiểu trong khoảng
thời gian mình à đi xe khách à đi về thì
mình có nghe podcast à và cũng tìm được
tìm vô tình tìm lại được cái podcast và
rất lâu rồi đó là của kênh Do
kênh này đăng cái video đấy phải 2 đến 3
năm rồi đấy nhưng mà hôm qua mình mới
nghe đấy thì cũng kênh đấy hồi trước là
làm video thuần về việc cảm tạo sáng tạo
nội dung các thứ các thứ ấy. À vẽ xong
rồi người ta là lồng tiếng xong rồi kết
hợp với vẽ hình ảnh minh họa khá là hay
nhưng mà
à hôm qua họ quyết định chuyển à không
phải hôm qua là mấy năm họ đã quyết định
chuyển qua podcast và mình thấy cũng rất
là hay. Mình cảm thấy là ừ thì thực ra
là mình kết hợp với cái mic này chắc là
giọng cũng có thể kiểu
đỡ đỡ đỡ mọi người. Ít nhất là mọi người
bảo nghe giọng mình cũng rung ngủ phần
nào nên chắc là cũng sẽ có thể hỗ trợ vụ
podcast được. Đấy. Thứ hai đó là
đây thứ mà các bạn đã nhìn thấy mình
đang tràn ngập tin nhắn ở trên trước mặt
ngày hôm nay đây. Đó là kiểu mình có
đăng ký tham gia cái 5 ngày làm cái gì
đó. Đây 5 ngày sử dụng AI để file coding
khóa học của Google miễn phí. Đấy mình
xin phép chia sẻ lại cái này cho các
bạn. Không biết các bạn còn đăng ký được
không? Thì đăng ký được thì tốt miễn phí
nên là tội gì đúng không? Đấy,
mình ghim ở đây nhá. Đấy, thì à thực ra
là mình thấy là
ừ chắc là mình nếu mà các bạn có theo
dõi trên Facebook của mình ấy thì các
bạn sẽ thấy là gần đây mình bị homo à
dùng từ gọi là gì nhỉ? sẽ khá là kiểu
mình sẽ khá là thần thánh hóa AI khá là
nhiều trong năm đổ lại đây. Đấy, thế nên
là mình kiểu cảm thấy là mình rất sợ
việc là mình lỡ bổ lỡ cái gì đó, mình
cần phải học thêm nó vân vân. Đấy. Thế
nên mình tham gia khóa học này cho dù rõ
ràng mình nghĩ là có thể là có thể là
mình biết rồi hoặc có thể là không áp
dụng gì cho mình cả rất nhiều cái nhưng
mà mình nghĩ là ừ mình phải đăng ký khóa
học xem thế nào và ít nhất mình nghe có
cái chứng chỉ nh chứng chỉ Google nó
cũng có gì đó đúng không ạ? À không
chứng chỉ cái Google này không biết phát
âm từ này nhá. Đấy nhưng mà nó có liên
kết Google nữa nghe xịn chắc thế đấy thì
đấy là lý do thứ hai khiến cho mình có
livestream ngày hôm nay tức là mình
tranh thủ lúc mà mình sẽ ngồi học có thể
ngồi học không các bạn luôn ngay bây giờ
đấy để mà mình vừa học vừa có người học
cùng thì nó cũng vui đúng không ạ? Đấy,
lý do thứ ba đó là
nho nhỏ thôi, đó là các bạn tự nhiên
thỉnh thoảng cái kênh Discord của mình
có người vào. Đấy, mình ngạc nhiên là
kiểu trong rất kiểu trong khoảng thời
gian mình có đăng một cái gì mới đâu nên
các bạn vẫn thỉnh thoảng biết đến kênh
YouTube với cả và kênh Discord của mình.
Nên là mình nghĩ là
ờ thì ờ
cũng ở một động lực gì đó các bạn cũng
có nhắc mình là kiểu ngồi học lại để họ
ngồi học để ôn phỏng vấn hay vân vân này
đấy động lực các thứ.
Em giờ mới bắt đầu khóa học của anh á.
Thì cái series này thì có khi hơi khó
cho em bởi vì anh đặt ở đây series này
là series thứ bảy đấy. Tức là em phải
học từ cái ờ playlist danh sách phát là
từ cái thứ nhất đấy
n không sao. Nói chung là các bạn thỉnh
thoảng nghe cái podcast của mình nghe.
Mục tiêu ấy, mục tiêu của cái kênh
YouTube nói chung của mình, mình xin
nhắc lại đó là thực ra không phải học
đâu mà chủ yếu là kiểu cũng gần như là
kiểu một nơi mình chia sẻ cuộc sống, góc
nhìn của một dân công nghệ thông tin.
Nếu mà các bạn đọc phần mô tả của mình
ấy thì là kéo một ông Wibu, một ông
Navi, á, một ông nên kiểu thế. Nghĩa là
à nó là kiểu chia sẻ góc nhìn, nó là
kiểu dạng à
để cho các bạn biết được ừ một ông à IT
à 97 không 96 cao làng nghề với khoa
ra đời các thứ thứ như nào bởi vì nhá
cũng rất là tình cờ nhá tình cờ là kiểu
hôm qua mình xem kênh Du mình vừa nói
thì là mấy người đấy cũng tầm tầm tuổi
và 27 28 29 gì đấy nhưng mà hình như
người ta lập gia đình rồi đấy thì đúng
là cái video đầu tiên của họ đăng cách
đây lâu lắm rồi 10 năm gì đấy và
nghĩa là họ họ tâm tuổi tôi mà nên là
thành ra là kéo cái tư tưởng hay cái suy
nghĩ của họ ấy cũng na ná cũng cứ cho là
na ná đi. Kiểu hôm qua họ cũng nói là
kiểu lâu lắm rồi tôi không đăng ở bởi vì
cuộc sống này sống các thứ thứ cạ gạm
tiền vân đại khái thế đấy nhưng mà cái
quan trọng là mình được phát triển cùng
với họ suốt khoảng thời gian đấy mình
cũng sẽ nhận ra mình thay đổi và họ cũng
sẽ thay đổi. Đấy giống như kiểu nói
chung là tôi có những cái à
kiểu đi cùng với mình có năm tháng thế
ví dụ giả sử như là anh JV Vi chẳng hạn
đấy anh JV Vi đó chỉ tôi bước vào đời từ
cấp ba đấy bây giờ thì mọi người sẽ thấy
anh ấy trưởng thành hơn rồi mọi thứ hơn
rồi các thứ đấy
đại khái là kênh của tôi tên là Blog
đúng không Nó là chia sẻ kiểu
là giống như cái hồi jagu ấy mình chia
sẻ một ký các thứ các suy nghĩ.
Thầy bảo học EQL trước nên học EQL đầu
tiên. Đúng rồi em học song song cả lập
trình web cũng được. Anh đang
kiểu am vào đâu hay cứ luyện thôi. Chính
xác là anh từng phỏng vấn ở một chỗ. Hiy
vọng sếp tôi không nghe được điều này.
Đấy và mọi thứ đều đẹp như tranh vẽ.
đẹp đến nỗi là tôi cứ tưởng là à không
hẳn là nghĩ lừa đảo giờ gặp rồi đấy. Cái
vụ mà tôi cảm thấy như lừa thì tôi đăng
lên YouTube các bạn thấy rồi [khịt mũi]
đấy. Còn à chưa đại khái thì họ lại yêu
cầu nhiều hơn so khả năng hiện tại của
tôi nên tôi nghĩ là ờ mình đã ngủ quên
khá là lâu rồi đến lúc mình phải ôn lại
các thứ đấy.
Chào anh em gọi tên em đi ạ. Ok. Em Hằng
Be
à? Đâu em Hang B
ờ đấy hơi hơi dài dòng rồi. Nói chung là
thực ra trong hôm nay tôi định là kiểu
một buổi chỉ tầm hơn tiếng đồng hồ chúng
ta sẽ ngồi kiểu cha hot à như hết sức
mệt để học làm cái gì đó. Đấy.
[khịt mũi]
Ờ tôi để link này mấy ông thấy rồi đúng
không nhỉ? Đấy mấy ông mà cảm thấy tiếng
Việt tiếng Anh khó quá thì
thì nói thật là các ông nên dù gì không
nên sợ nó vẫn phải à
ờ vẫn phải biết một ít và [khịt mũi]
có thể dùng tiện ích hay mọi thứ bên
cạnh để mà dịch nhưng mà chủ yếu là các
ông đừng có ngại nó đặc biệt theo ngành
công nghệ thông tin này. Đấy, một trong
những cái mà tôi bị kiểu gọi là điểm trừ
khi đi buổi phóng vấn hôm đấy là bởi vì
tiếng Anh tôi là tôi ổn nhá. Tôi muốn tự
tin là tiếng Anh tôi rất rất ổn nhưng là
giao tiếp không đủ nhiều. Nghĩa là cái
độ phản xạ mình rất là thấp nên là thành
hôm đấy là tôi toàn phải nói song ngữ.
Tôi nói tiếng Việt trước rồi tôi mới nói
tiếng Anh kiểu thế nó đã không ổn rồi
đấy. Nên là mấy ông mà ngại thế là mấy
ông tự giới hạn bản thân thôi đúng không
ạ? Đấy tôi có biết những người sếp tôi
biết rất giỏi làm PM làm từng làm CTO
vân vân vân nhưng tiếng Anh của họ lại
kiểu
vẫn còn bị hạo chế. Đấy
ba số tôi quen rất nhiều nhá. Đấy tự
nhiên họ lại bị giới hạn họ sẽ chỉ tìm
những cái và khi mà chúng ta đến tầm
tuổi nào đó rồi chúng ta học ngoại ngữ
nó bị ngại hay bị rất nhiều cái hơn đúng
không? Đấy nên là họ chỉ vào từ những
công ty Việt Nam thôi, trong nước thôi.
Thậm chí là kể cả công ty trong nước c
nữa mà làm đối tác với nước ngoài đôi
khi là họ yêu cầu gì đó tự nhiên lại
mình lại bị
chỉ đơn giản thôi nhá. Chỉ đơn giản
thôi. Đó là riêng việc ông có chứng chỉ
nước ngoài đôi khi nó tăng phần lương
của ông ngay trong công ty đấy rồi đấy.
Nên là nếu có thể thì cái gì học được
thì học đúng không ạ? Đặc biệt là ngoại
ngữ. Đ ok bắt đầu nhá.
Đ
tôi định bán là hôm nay tôi đã ghi mô tả
của cái video hôm nay là song ngữ nên
tôi định bắn tiếng Anh ở đây. Nếu mà mấy
ông cảm thấy tiếng Anh tôi rất tệ thì
thôi xin lỗi nhé.
Is a summary of how the work and detail
instruction on how to set up. Get set
up.
Ok.
system design để sau hả thầy? Ờ
chính xác là đúng như thế. Tức là
[khịt mũi]
ờ đáng hẹ chuẩn là cái khóa này là để ôn
chủ yếu là
hệ thống session design và
à không đang định bảo và Java nhưng mà
Java tôi nhớ tôi tch một cái Java rồi
nhưng mà đang nói là ờ cái này lúc đầu
để cho system design nhưng mà tôi nghĩ
là tôi làm trước cái này tôi lấy cái
chứng trị đã và thậm chí là tôi sẽ chia
sẻ cho anh em gần đây là tôi đã dùng EAI
như nào đấy. Đấy, còn về session design
đấy kiểu gì tôi cũng sẽ
trả bài cho anh em. Còn trong 5 ngày tới
hi vọng đủ 5 ngày thì tôi sẽ cố làm được
cái khóa học này. Hack thon mà đấy. 4
ngày nữa. Ok không ạ?
Tôi không nhớ tôi đăng nhập cái gì nữa.
Nhớ đăng nhập.
Ui lộ email mất rồi. Chắc mấy ông có khi
m ông biết sử email của tôi rồi. Nói tôi
nhớ ở trước là có một cái
video là nó tôi bị à đánh cờ à
trên YouTube thì cái tội để lộ thông tin
cá nhân. Không biết là lộ thông tin cá
nhân mình có bị tính thế không?
Sao đây là năm buổi học khóa học năm
buổi online đúng không ạ? 5 ngày đấy.
by Google researcher
and engineer
powerful
production system ok explore codingal
primary
interface
đây phải x10 lên đấy
bài
Inter
ừ tôi quên mất tôi phải cài cả cái
Gemini các thứ thứ nữa người ta yêu cầu
phải cài
Gini
xong rồi an à anti Gravity ui nhiều lắm
ở khng động lại hạ cái đấy
đây đây đây đấy down thứ thứ Đây
đây
đây antirapity 2.
Ok
tôi đang dùng M ông nào chưa biết
rồi bị đột rồi chắc không sao đâu.
Ok. Một cái
dùng hết đúng này luôn ạ. Ok.
Ok.
Hello sir. The sound is a bit low. I
have turn.
Thế á. Đây mấy ông nghe rõ chưa ạ? Bởi
vì à
kiểu vừa nãy để cho nó kiểu độ nhạy thấp
ấy mà tôi cũng nói hơi hơi bé một tí.
Chắc là lâu không nói chuyện. Đấy. Thế
là to chưa ạ? Độ nhạy cao quá thì tôi sợ
là kiểu
nó bị dính cái bên ngoài tạp âm bên
ngoài vào. Còn nói to thì thực ra tôi
vẫn nói to được đấy. Thích gao mic cũng
được nhở.
Thôi rồi anh. Ok. Tiếng Anh nó tự động
dịch Big Brother.
Ok.
Đâu cái này chạy thôi. Tôi dùng cái grap
để chạy à. Thay terminal không ạ?
Mấy ông không biết cái này. Tôi thấy cái
này ngon phết.
dạng gần đây tôi kiểu bị kiểu hơi a
kiểu gọi nhở không bảo mật lắm. Tức là
có lệnh nào trông hay hãy bấm vào rồi
cho nó toán quyến.
Chắc không biết có phải do cậy mình đang
trên ma không trên trên ma thật ra là
hồi trước tôi đã có đọc một cái mọi
người bảo trên ma khó hack hơn thế về
sau tôi đọc thêm thì thực ra nó bảo là
thực ra là trên ma không hẳn là khó hack
hơn chẳng qua là lượng người dùng
Windows đông hơn và bạn cập nhật hay nói
chung nó rối rán vân vân vân hơn ý đấy
nên là người ta thằng này cố tấn công
vào lượng người dùng ở trên Windows hơn
chứ không phải nói là ma khó hack hơn.
Đấy thử thầy
đã thử appo
container chưa? Uầy, chưa ngay bao giờ
luôn.
Tôi sẽ lưu lại ở đâu đó. Tôi lưu lại ở
đâu? Ở trên này cũng không có sticking
note. Tôi sẽ mở cái
không biết là có cái gì cả. Đây không à.
Đây sẽ là Apple
container. Ok. Nó giống kiểu đức cơ đúng
không? Nghe giống kiểu đứ cơ mà đúng
không?
Đúng rồi. Thiên kiến sống sót. Uầy. Đấy
ông kia nói cái từ rất là chuẩn. Đấy
nghĩa là chỉ là để đánh giá một cái gì
đó. Đi khi chúng ta hơi kiểu
cứ thấy số đông nhiều như thế mình sẽ
nghĩ là à chứng tỏ là cái đấy nó
là như thế. sẽ kiểu thế mình sẽ dùng số
đông để đánh giá cái gì đó đương nhiên
là thiết kế sống sắc nó không hoàn toàn
như thế nhá tôi đang ví dụ thế nhưng chỉ
mình đa số mình th nhìn vào đa số để
đánh giá toàn bộ tổng quát đấy và không
hề nhận ra là bài toán thực ra là nó còn
lớn hơn thế nghĩa là cái đa số hiện tại
là chẳng qua là nó là đã trải qua rất
nhiều cái đôi khi là chỉ trải qua một
cái sự thông min lọc nhất định đúng
không
Tự tự nhiên chảy ra tôi vừa rồi tôi lại
nghĩ cái nó cũng na thế
không biết có nhạy cảm hay không như na
là thế kiểu bây giờ chẳng đánh giá kiểu
cả ví dụ là kiểu hồi trước tôi nhớ tôi
nhớ có một đứt nữa nào đấy
đứt nữa nào đấy hình như là hồi trước
thậm chí còn Nga tức là kể
à là tỉ lệ phụ nữ so với nam giới đông
hơn đấy sau chiến tranh sau sau từ đó
kết luận là phụ nữ trong chiến tranh sẽ
sống sót dễ hơn đàn ông thực ra bởi vì
đàn ông đi lẫm trận hết rồi thì đương
nhiên kinh kến sống sót ở đây chẳng thấp
hơn xong rồi lại kêu là tuổi thọ của phụ
nữ cao hơn trung bình cao hơn lương
mấy ông đủ tuổi mấy ông đi xâm
Xung trận hết rồi
đấy. Đấy là một trong những cái thành
kiến sống sót đây.
Ok. Cài một đống này rồi.
Bên này bị spam quá nhiều ấy mấy ông
nhìn không?
Không dám mở thông báo luôn ý.
Ờ
chẳng lẽ tôi lại dùng AI trong trường
hợp này đọc đúng.
Không ba không cần. Ok. Giới thiệu
xem video này
để hoàn thành đọc cái này rồi để hoàn
thành cái col gì đó sử dụng cái này là
ok. Tạo một web application và deploy on
thứ bạn sẽ được học. What you will
learn. Đấy. Today white paper talk
coding
máy h được sử dụng AI trong trường hợp
này. Bây giờ bảo tôi ngồi code Python
tôi biết Python dòng nào đâu.
Đấy.
Ok.
Ồ Studio nữa. Được.
Ờ. Ui nhưng mà tôi xem cái này cùng mấy
ông tôi không biết là tôi có bị
như nào
ăn bản quyền không nhỉ? Ăn gậy không
nhỉ?
Tí nhá. Thôi xin phép tôi để ở chỗ khác
để tránh bị ông nào chắc là không nào
ông nào ở đây rảnh đánh gậy tôi
ơ không có nút
AI tóm tắt ở đây ở bình thường tôi thấy
có cái nút AI tóm tắt đây mà nhở.
Đâu rồi?
Tắt đĩa riêng video tắt đỉa
đỡ. Ok
thử white paper xem nào.
Giả sử không xem video bất chấp coi như
là tao chuyên đào không có xem thử à
đây file coding như
đây đọc toàn bộ cái đống bên dưới này
file coding nhưng vẫn cần đọc
không có file code lắm.
Ok.
Đây chữ mà đúng không? Chẳng lẽ tôi lạm
dụng AI tôi bảo AI tóm tắt luôn này tôi
xem nào. Được tôi sẽ vào tm tắt đi. Tôi
lười rồi. 51 tràng. Úi giời ơi
đâu
tắt
bây giờ đến giờ rồi tôi sẽ dùng con là
với việc sử dụng văn bản sẽ dùng thằng
codex còn nếu mà code hay gì gì đó tôi
sẽ dùng à cloud à đúng rồi nhưng mà mình
phải cài đúng này ấ nhở đúng cài xong
chư
Anti bởi vì anti gravity a
đúng kéo notebook cũng được
kiểu gọi nhở anh quen dùng với cái kia
hơn thôi à book cũng là một cách nha
book lm ấy
ơ ơ ơ đợi tôi một tí ấy sai sai ở đây.
Lâu lắm rồi động lại antig đâ ạ.
Hồi trước c bạn còn có tài khoản Google
AI Pro cơ mà bây giờ không có gì cả.
Đây thì dùng C. Ok.
À review
sao?
Never request for review.
Ok.
Ồ
bu for Google
sau
trong lại.
Ch lạ phết
trong giao diện nào cũng hoành tráng hơn
một tí.
Ừ.
Xem
antiravity bình thường xem nào.
Được rồi. ID cho nó mở hết lên xem thế
nào đấy.
Nhưng mà
ừ ok để tôi
vừa nãy tôi có tài liệu ở đây đúng
không?
Đấy, tôi tạo mất cái mục trong này đi. À
đây sẽ là color
nhậ
đúng
chuẩn luôn. CL đấy. Tôi bật cái tài liệu
này vào đây.
Ok. Tài nhệm day one tạo thư mục day one
luôn đấy. Trong này
mở th mục
rồi ngay tiếp đăng nhập nhiều chế.
Ok
rồi
nãy giờ đá lẽ tôi phải chuẩn bị mấy cái
này trước xin lỗi mấy không
tôi có hành cố ra phạ cái này đọc
từ đâu vậy cái này từ antivatic cũ à sao
có
cái cũ lắm rồi này
để Để tôi thử xem dùng được à
để tôi xem tôi dùng được cái kia nhá.
Đi full chi đi. Ok ok
ok.
Tôi đang có
[khịt mũi] file PDF
đó.
Đây đây đúng không? Rồi
à đâu trong file luôn ấ nhỉ? Có hẳn file
luôn mà.
À quên không giống cố so chúng ta bây
giờ chúng ta sẽ chơi
gi. Ok.
File tài liệu.
Thực ra nếu mà chuẩn ra tôi định làm nhá
sẽ là
đây.
Đợi tôi tí đợi tôi một tí làm. Bây giờ
mình lỡ làm nó chuẩn thô nhá.
Mình sẽ có
cái file ở ngoài cùng này đi.
File bit with me đi.
Chm đi.
Đấy. Ui còn ảnh. Ui giời có ảnh à. Mình
copy ra đây. Có ảnh xịn phết nhỉ. AMD có
ảnh đấy. Xem à. Ok. Ok.
Rồi
và hôm nay có ngày 1 đúng không ạ?
Đấy trước cái quà mình sẽ copy cái
require về
đây như này
đây.
Đây sẽ có Redmi cũng được
đâ. Ok
đọc
tóm tắt cho tôi ra một file MD
medium à medium chạ được một gì nhỉ
Ừ thường là
thường là cách prom của tôi gần đây nó
sẽ là đầu tiên là input này context
input là những cái gì mình nạp vào này
tch là nội kiểu bối cảnh các thứ đúng
không ạ
đọc
À không, trước đấy đã vì vừa rồi là nếu
mấy ông để ý là vừa rồi tôi đã copy các
thứ các thứ vào trong cái này high file
Redmi đúng không? Tôi muốn sửa lại cái
file Redmi đấy trước để biến nó thành
một cái nội dung mà kiểu hiệu ích cho
AI. Từ đó là về sau mình cứ ở trong cái
thư mục nào mình dùng cái file Redmi đấy
để mình biết được, mình khai thác thêm
thông tin để biết được là ok mình đang
cần làm gì. Đấy.
Ừ.
skin đển
đ các ph
hữu ích à thông tin qu
mô t
file
không ru đi như nào
x
ch
sử dụng
thường à tôi sẽ th bảo là câu cuối của
ừ
ừ câu cuối của mấy cái này thường sẽ gì
nhỉ? Ừ,
hỏi lại tôi
để xác nhận
lâu và
cách bác xử lý
hãnh lên đề xuất
cho phù hợp thế.
Vâng là nó sẽ chế độ mình để chế độ plan
mode mà trong này tôi không thấy plan
mode plan mode ở đâu cả.
Cái này limit nhưng mà cái này không
limit.
Ô ok.
Lố lắm là không dừng antiravity. Hi vọng
là kiểu nó không gây mình thất vọng thì
kiểu vừa hỏi một câu rei không làm được
cái gì cả.
Đây đây mặc định plan mode luôn ạ.
À không không cần thông báo gì đâu. phải
mặc định plan luôn plan mode luôn script
chẩn đồ tự động này
không cần file
tôi sẽ
kết
đó để
biến
Ty
file skill này.
Bởi vì nó đã gợi ý mấy cái file các thứ
thứ này hợp lý rồi.
để
tặng
file
kia
6.
Cái này tại sao phải có cái file này
nhỉ? Tôi chưa hình dung lắm.
Đặt nội dung bất kỳ từ file có thể tôi
chuyển động không căn.
Okúng là trên mini flash lâu lắm là
không động vào cũng nhanh phết. Tôi dùng
à
cloud off với
codex 5.5 xong rồi còn để hai ấ ui ta
nói đợi nửa tiếng đồng hồ. Đúng rồi.
Công nhận nhìn lâu lắm đọc lại cái này
nhanh vèo vèo vèo th đấy. Ok. Kit me
convers cái thứ
thối tà tạo rồi à nhanh đấy.
Ui ta tạo xong rồi. Ok xịn lá.
Ok ngon luôn.
skill đúng không nhỉ? Trong trường hợp
này mình tạo gọi là command hay skill
nhở? Tôi nghĩ ở trong trường này có
command đúng kiểu lệnh ấy. Để mình gõ
lệnh cái này.
Q
chọn này
lại phải skill đúng tôi nghĩa skill đổi
thành số command cho tôi để
rồi này là được
không phải sử đâu. Nhấn nhấm
đây là sau mình sẽ dùng command ở đây để
mà mình nhét thêm cái file Redmi vào sẽ
tự tậng tạo ra một cái file kiểu
các thứ thứ cho mình
đây
chỗ Ok.
Ok.
Tôi thường là tôi đến lúc là tôi muốn
tắt cái
tôi sẽ tắt cái function đi.
Đây hỏi nhiều quá
sao?
Access
không cho nó không quyền rồi nhỉ? Không
quyền đâu rồi?
Ph quyền đâu rồi?
Chắc cho nó phung quyền ở trong này luôn
mà nhỉ?
đâ
đây
to xong Ok.
Vẫn bị hỏi ạ.
Tại sao phải dùng mấy cái này nhỉ?
Ch mini 3.5
bây giờ có trên mini 3.5 bình thường pro
không nhỉ?
Hả?
Quay cam lại đi anh á.
Ừ.
Cam trông đang tệ nhỉ. Thu cố kia đâu để
tôi xem nào. Đợi tí.
À hồi trước là chơi cái trò dùng cái a
gọi nhợ
tí đợi tí
tôi tắt cái
background remove. Ok. Ôi thế này hơi
lộn quá.
xem mở lại vậy à.
Thôi tắt sư bác ra remove nhanh
tắt đi.
Ok chưa ạ? Rồi.
Flip á?
À
anh đâu sao?
Anh lại thấy quen tay bên này hơn em ạ.
Thế
em thấy tay bên ngược lại sẽ đỡ hơn à?
Xem nào. Cái chỗ flip ở đâu nhở?
Trong phố và à trong
horizon
đây không? Anh trông kiểu này trông
thôi. Sao?
Ừ, thế này trông quen hơn đấy.
Ok, cảm ơn em.
Không xem cái này. Không xem cái này.
Ok.
Đây cách một tạo cái gì? cách một á
cần làm luôn nhưng mà nó lại bảo cách
một cách hai mình
tạo thứ
không phải
thì tôi là có để tôi sử dụng
trong
các ai
ch
à nó có prompting ạ
xem nào.
Tôi thích thấy sai sai kiểu gì nó bị hơi
bị đi xa quá không? Tôi không sao. Ok.
Mình làm tiếp. Tôi lại thấy Yemini có
cái điểm nhược điểm nó ở đây rồi. Ừ
không tôi lâu lắm không dùng con này.
Vẫn đều đều gì ấy. Nó chỉ được cái nhanh
thôi không ạ?
Ok thử tổng tắt tài liệu đây nhá.
À
này coding này c
repair
cài python đọc cái này hiệu này complete
chưa hiểu lắm
và tôi thấy khó chịu mấy cái này rồi.
Tôi bắt đầu khó chịu cái này rồi. Tôi
xin phép tôi quay lại thằng còn codex
của tôi đây.
ơ đằng
nh
đợi đi
xóa cái linh tinh này đi
tình
ồ ok
ừ đang Có
file Redmi này
biến nó tiện
tiếng Việt đi dù rõ ràng cái nãy không
đừng nên ngại tiếng Anh
ờ
ừ
và
gì nhở
Tạo bộ tu chống dịch
6 tối
à không
tối sau tối có thể
Tay đ
sẽ
do ánh sáng hay sao mà thầy đã đến
vậy?
À ý ông là ra bị một tối á.
Có thể gần đây tôi nên ra thật tôi không
để ý a
tôi vố tôi không để ý ngoại hình lắm cái
hợp việc không chăm sóc được. Đây tôi mở
hết lên cho ông sáng sáng nhá. Được
chưa?
Đấy, bây giờ không phải là
da đen nữa mà sẽ chuyển qua là da vàng.
Command để sau này tôi có thể dùng
engine kết thà liệu sẽ
tạo tóm tắt
tiếng Anh tiếng à
gọn
tiếng Việt.
t
đấy.
Ừ. Tôi th dùng chế độ L mode trước này.
Ừ.
lại tôi đề được 6
phân tích
đâu
đ sách
tế ok để thử xem nhá xem con này sao
nhì mini nh ơ hai mới cập nhật này trong
hai phết
Ồ
mấy ông thấy cái này cái gì không? Tôi
đã cài cloud kit và nó có tích hợp được
báo trong codex
chớ.
Ok
đây cô
vừa mới hỏi câu ngắn gọn 5% luôn ạ.
Tốn thật đấy.
Tất ng vứt vào do đ command đây là file
cấu hình dữ dớ đấy
đấy xịn nó phải khác biệt thằng yumy
miễn phí cùi quá
hiện tại nó cũng khá gọn các thứ từ tớ
sẽ học
tác thao tác cận là
ok
b T
đơn giản
wifi
anh không học nữa. Java nữa à?
Java chắc phải sau đấy rất xa. Nghĩa là
đầu tiên thì mấy ông phải ngồi xem lại
cái buổi đầu tiên tôi học Java. Lý do
tôi học Java là gì? Không phải học Java
để làm ngôn ngữ Java mà học Java là bởi
vì [khịt mũi]
tôi muốn bởi vì là mình đã chuyên sâu
vào một ngôn ngữ rồi là PP và cụ thể là
Royal ấy nên là
sẽ có đếm cái ngưỡng mà mình gọ không
học thêm được mấy nữa mà học thêm thì nó
sẽ chỉ học về công nghệ của cái ngôn ngữ
đấy chứ không học về cái bản chất của
lập trình cũng như là ví dụ là kiến trúc
hay mọi thứ hay để túi ưu vân vân vân
vân ưu nhược của từng cái mình phải học
những cái kiểu song song những cái kiểu
những cái ngôn ngữ khác nữa đúng không
cũng là ngôn ngữ bậc cao các thứ để biết
được là thế mạnh ưu nhược của từng thằng
thì từ đó mình kiểu
biết tận dụng cái thằng nào thằng nào
nói chung mình sẽ không bị phụ thuộc vào
một ngôn ngữ nữa học Java không phải để
tôi làm Java mà có thể là nhảy sang được
ngôn ngữ nào khác nữa. phía sau có thể
học ngôn ngữ khác nữa nhá, không phải
mũi Java. Đấy thì à đấy là một. Thứ hai
là tôi bây giờ đang hơi ưu tiên một tí
là sẽ phải học về cả AI này và cả về
design button à design system là về hệ
thống. Tức là bởi vì bây giờ thì tôi thì
kêu cứ tự gán mio nhưng mà thực ra là ở
trên công ty của tôi được động ở hệ
thống rất là ít. Đấy thì trước này cũng
không có chủ động tìm hiểu về hệ thống
thì bây giờ đến lúc mà tôi sẽ phải
thực ra tôi có hiểu cách hoạt động nó
man na nám mọi thứ như nào nhá. Vì chính
tôi cũng từng kiểu làm việc trực tiếp
với nó để giải quyết hay fixb các thứ
mà. Nhưng mà bây giờ thực sự là mình
phải hiểu rõ nó để mình đi phỏng vấn
được này. Đấy, mục tiêu của tôi vẫn là
để đi phỏng vấn đã. Đấy, sau đó thì học
thêm dần dần dần cái gì đó thì thêm nữa.
Ok không ạ?
Đây
dựng hết chéo
hỏi về câu mất 9%
đấy. Đấy, xong rồi. Cũng nhanh đúng
không? Cũng nhanh đúng không? Mỗi khi là
tôi phải đợi nửa tiếng. Chắc là mấy cái
này ngắn gọn chưa có gì cả.
Ok. À đấy, một cái nữa cho mấy ông đó là
khi mà mấy ông có cái này đúng không?
Chụp cái chế độ plan mode là ra được một
cái file plan như thế này, kế hoạch các
thứ thứ như này đúng không?
sẽ mở cái chat mới. Đấy, copy mở chat
mới như này. Đấy, xong rồi bạn làm cho
tôi. Lúc này không cần nghĩ nhiều nữa,
chia độ bình thường hơn. Tại sao lại như
thế? Bởi vì là nếu mà ông chat luôn vào
trong cái kia thì nó sẽ AI nó không nhớ
được
mình đã làm gì đâu. Mà cách để nó nhớ ấ
nó sẽ thường xuyên là gửi lại cái đoạn
hội thoại chat từ trước đến nay bao gồm
của cả ông và nó gửi lên sẽ khá tốn
Windows context với tùng token của ông
thôi.
Thế á?
Alo. Nói vừa rồi nói bé.
Ok. Tôi to hết cỡ đấy. Hình vọng mấy ông
thấy đỡ hơn.
Vừa rồi nó bé à? Hay là do cái
đây thấy to hơn chưa? Alo alo. À tôi tôi
nhớ.
Đợi đợi tôi một tí. Tôi nhớ lý do rồi.
Thằng thằng à map nó bị cái a
thằng map nó bị cái này
không biết mấy ông biết không nói bị cái
này
mic à
đây mấy ông thấy tự nhiên nó chỉnh của
tôi bé lại không
đấy Nghĩa
là bị một cái là kiểu hồi trước tôi thấy
cả Win và M hồi trước nó bị một cái a là
kiểu mình nói to quá ấy nó tự động nó
chỉnh lại cái âm lượng mình kiểu bé lại
không biết để làm gì nó tự động luôn ý
không tắt được cái này không biết bây
giờ có tắt được không nhưng mà hồi trước
của tôi không tắt được hồi đấy tôi phải
ờ tôi phải kiểu gọi như này viết cái
đoạn script
chạy 5 giây một lần thì nó tự động lên
lại 100%. Đấy, Windows hở trước cũng bị
nhá. Nhưng mà Windows hở trước tôi chỉ
bị ở trên a Google Meet, trên Google
Meet thôi. Tức là Google Meet nó có cái
đoạn script nào nó tự động chỉnh cái lại
cái mic của mình đấy.
Ừ. để bảo vệ người nghe nhưng mà nó ông
hiểu đấy. Mục tiêu của mình là để lên
max xong cuối cùng thì nó bé lại bảo vệ
người nghe.
Ok.
Chúng ổn à? Ồ cũng suy nghĩ rất xấu xa
với người tầm thường như tôi sẽ không
hiểu được cái điều đấy. Đây mấy ông thấy
nghe to hơn nhiều chưa? Được rồi đúng
không? Tôi [âm nhạc] cũng nghe thấy rõ.
Có vẻ rõ hơn rồi. Nó chạm mức đó. Tôi cứ
đeo tai nghe mà. Tôi đeo tai nghe để mà
biết được mình đang nói như nào mà.
Nhưng mà đúng là nãy giờ không để ý việc
à nó đang bị bé hơn thật.
Nghe rõ rồi đúng không? Ok.
Đấy mấy ông không nói vì tức là đôi khi
là mình sẽ rơi vào cái điểm mù là chính
bản thân mình không biết được mình đang
thế nào ấy. Đấy có người nói còn không
thì mình sẽ mình không biết thôi.
Nó còn gọi như là nó còn kiểu thành xấu
hổ ấy. Kiểu giống như là kiểu với trước
có người bảo là kiểu ta đi cả ngày ở
ngoài đường xong rồi biết là tao quên
kéo phép nó tuy chẳng hạn. kiểu thế n
không ai nói mình đâu nhưng mình sẽ cứ
ôm cái xấu hổ đấy mãi.
Chào anh. Anh phỏng vấn cho vị trí nào
thế? Anh phỏng vấn cho vị trí chuẩn là
sino full stack à nhưng full stack nhưng
mà thực ra là nó lại larel với view.
Thực ra react cũng được. Anh gần đây
cũng có vẻ dùng ai mà lại
mình cũng có thể code được nhiều cái
đấy.
Ok. Các file có vẻ được tạo thôi.
Đây xem xem thử cái quả read me này nhá.
Khóa học 5 ngày các thứ thớ tóm tắt
nhanh trực tiến lên phía mô tả. Hàng
ngày sẽ có assignment
và các thứ. Tuy nhiên là tôi thấy một
trong cái nó rất là hay đó là nó dịch
nhưng mà nó vẫn sẽ giữ được những cái từ
khóa chuyên ngành tránh việc là nó dịch
hết toàn bộ. Bởi vì có nhiều cái từ
tiếng Anh không dịch ra nó bị tấu nghĩa
ấy, khó hiểu ấy đúng không? Đấy nó để từ
khóa trên ngành này rất là hay. Nhưng mà
đương nhiên có vài từ đúng rồi. Tôi
không biết thật nhá. Kiểu cái này đánh
giá này. Hôm trước hình như tôi mới phải
trao lại từ này tôi đánh giá này
kể tham gia này các thứ.
Ok hôm nay sẽ ch làm quen với cái này
dùng go studio
focus cho
cái unit này bằng cái này bán các thứ
thứ
nghe tầ làm nghe này đọc này hoàn thành
c tác L
để lại và theo dõi livestream
tư lại link để xem có
đâ từ xem tóm tắt
đấy tố
cái command nào nhỉ? Rồi c
đợi tí để t
đây.
Seri à?
Ừ.
Ty
m nghĩ sâu sâu một tí.
Một hồi em đọc kiểu này chuyển qua full
tiếng Anh luôn cho lệ
không. Nhưng mà cái file kia dài mà file
PDF này tậng 55 trang mà. Nên là trong
trường hợp này mình mình đang mình đang
học khóa học AI mà tận dụng AI chứ. Bây
giờ mình kiểu mình thấy lười quá mình
chuyển qua ngồi làm chay thì
mất ý nghĩa khóa học đúng không?
AI
đấy tôi tôi lạm dụng AI gần đây mèo
ngoại sẽ bị không cảm
chỉ ghi câu hỏi mở nên tay được cho rõ
chị TCH để tránh đoán tính phải tao gửi
bài này mà saợ toán đoán tên file gì nữa
nhỉ
có tâm
chentic
hanes hanes này
han
này vân đây phổ biến phết kiểu tôi thấy
là kiểu
nhắc nhiều tôi cũng chưa biết là tôi đã
động tí phần nào về cái h này chưa
Thế à? Tại sao bảo tạo và cập nhật cái
cái này nhỉ?
Đây tool cập tệ này. Sunbox này
review cia
tăng nhỏ giao trình làm việc mềm tập
quản lý phàn hồi của thứ cái này thực ra
mấy cái này tôi biết nhưng mà đang xanh
lắm
ừ
viết ra mang đ cho tôi và vì đây là khóa
học
của Google
lặp lại RM
công cụ của Google
nó đang bảo là viết ra cái agent này là
không đúng lắm này vì à
đương nhiên là vừa nãy có tạo cái file
agent trong cái này rồi nhưng mà ý tôi
là bây giờ Giờ mình đang khám khóa
Google là mình sẽ phải dùng Gemini rồi
anti Gravity đúng không? Đấy mình viết
ru sẽ phải viết nói chung là làm mọi thứ
cũng sẽ theo mấy cái file đấy chứ không
phải là
đây đây nó đang vịt hóa xong rồi nó còn
tự vào trong của Codex không chuẩn.
Anh biết xài skin này nọ không?
xài skin thì thại gọi như này đây. Nãy
giờ nó cũng tự động này. Nó tự động sử
dụng skin. Nghĩa là bản chất skin nó
skin này hay là
command kia bản chất toàn bộ nó là cái
file down kiểu nó là cái prom mẫu thôi.
Nó có chứa những cái kiểu kiểu ghi rõ ở
trong đấy là cái workflow nên làm như
nào xong kiểu r mọi thứ như nào vân vân
vân ấy skin nó không phải cái gì đâu.
quá kiểu ghê gớm thôi. Anh cảm thấy là
kiểu về sau anh làm nhiều anh thấy mấy
đây gớm. Chẳng qua mình những cái những
cái mình viết ở trong skin là khi mà
mình thấy nó lập đi lại thì mình viết nó
thành một cái skin đóng gói nó thành bộ
prom thế. Thay vì mỗi lần em a em viết
prom em viết lại dài theo kiểu rất rất
nhiều cái mụ yêu cầu này nọ ấy em thấy
nó bị lạp hiệp bạn thì sẽ biết nó lại
thành
nó không phải mỗi Macdaan nó làm
workflow á
đúng đúng anh biết được nó bao gồm cả
workflow trong đấy nghĩa là bản chất là
nó vẫn là file prom thôi nó vẫn là file
kiểu bình thường nghĩa là em sẽ trong
skin đấy em sẽ ra lệnh nhận thêm những
cái là kiểu các kiểu em ghi rõ các kiểu
em làm em dùng cái tool gì hay vân vân
vân đấy đúng không? Nó vẫn là prom thôi
mà tức là em thích em gõ tay cái đấy ra
cũng được. Đấy chẳng qua là
thì bản chất của skin đấy đấy anh tham
khảo từ chính la code nhận xét về skin
nhá. Tức là cái cái
prom nào cái đoạn lệnh nào em cứ phải gõ
đi gõ lại trong mỗi lần em chat với ai
đấy thì nó tổng hợp nó lại thành một cái
skin để mà xong anh chỉ cần gọi lại nó
là được. Đấy kiểu như thế
tế nhiên là trong đấy bao gồm những cái
gì thì đấy em có thể tùy tùy biến đúng
không? Mình
đọc trở lại trực tiếp các thứ AI Studio
đúng rồi trên API đúng rồi
thứ
đâu xem xem lại cái bản ui mở lắm thế
thì tắt cái thằng này đi dùng mỗi thằng
này cho này Ok.
À
giải thích cách đang viết từ khối pháp
sang diễn đạt ý định này. Chạy test sở
đổi trang bị tài khoản
kiểm tra.
Nếu mà cái này không có thì dặm
Anh thấy là đúng cái khóa này kiểu dành
cho mấy người cơ bản chưa biết tí gì chứ
không phải là một cái ừ
gì ghê gớm cả. Mấy cái này tất cả mấy
cái này mình đều biết nhỉ. C thứ duy
nhất mà tôi chưa làm thì nó là dùng à
kiểu Google Studio để mà kiểu deploy tự
động deploy thôi. Nhưng mà anh nghĩ mấy
cái này đơn giản quá.
Ừ. Thôi qua gọi bỏ qua đi ạ. Mình chuyển
qua
bây giờ chất lượng giới sinh viên và số
lượng sao đó anh ờ
à không ví dụ đây thôi chứ tôi đã đi dậy
quay lại đi dạy đâu
nhưng mà đúng năm ngoái năm ngoái năm
kia có đi dạy lại thì các bạn làm dụng
ai hơn thật nhưng mà nó hơi khó đánh giá
bởi Thì à
à thôi tí tôi sẽ chat trong này tiện. À
đây 100 ngày thôi. Chúng ta quay lại
ngồi ship design đi. Tôi thấy cái bài
kia linh tinh quá không đáng để học
hôm nay. Bởi vì bây giờ cũng muộn rồi.
Tôi sẽ ngồi chỉ trả lời
được một cái là tốt.
À đâu hôm nay cũng một cái mà xem này.
Một cái mà.
Đây.
System design
sao? À
đợi tí nhá. Đợi tí nhá. Nói chung là cái
a
project này liên tình. Tôi sẽ tạo hẳn
một project nữa đi. Nó tên là
system
design. Đấy. Ok. Mặc định là hôm nay
đang lẽ phải là buổi sóng 1 nhưng mà
vì đây cũng không sao nó ghi ngày một
mà. Ok. Hộp lý đây đúng không?
Tiếp theo là
giợi thì tạo một cái thươ mục mới nhá.
Ui nh
ch
ok
tôi sẽ tạo page lại một loạt chữ từ đây
nhé.
Xong rồi tôi sẽ cho anh em xem lại cái
yêu cầu đề bài các thứ.
Ừ.
À quên luôn phải file RME đầu tiên dài
quá ném qua disc.
gì nhỉ? Đợi tí tôi phải viết cái Redmi
đầu tiên đã. Quết mất start một cái mới
có bị ảnh hưởng không nhỉ? Có đúng
không?
Thôi không sao. À đầu tiên là ừ
trích xuất chữ từ các ảnh sau
vào
file cho những thư mục
đây.
Đ không cần khóa cao xê
anti tập xử lý tôi đánh chỗ c hơn
tôi sẽ mở cái th mục này Đ
ok
cho dù anti vừa rồi trông đẹp thật đẹp
hơn công nhận đẹp hơn
chưa để làm gì lắm
đang tồn tại các thứ thứ
cái ok đề bài các thứ các thứ đúng không
ạ
ok file được tạo các thứ rồi tiếp theo
mình sẽ tạo một cái file tạo cho tôi
file
ping
của project này
và
à rất nghi đúng không nhỉ?
R
à mục tiêu là tôi sẽ đăng
ông kia cái fanpage bảo là
100 ngày à system design xong rồi cuối
cùng nó không đăng gì thêm c
à đâu
đang đến ngày 9 rồi dừng lại
lừa cũng được không sao ngày 9 là chúng
ta có chín buổi livestream rồi thế tốt
rồi
ừ
ti đăng vào đây
có đề
dịch à xuất chữ từ đó tôi sẽ
để trao đổi và
xài
học
thiết kế hệ thống
để thành senior đấy.
Đây tôi đã có nhiều đề hơn rồi. sẽ vượt
bớt đây trong này.
Đây là ngày 9 này, ngày 8 này,
ngày à
ngày 7 này,
ngày 6.
5 này.
ok.
12 cũng ok luôn.
Đấy, tôi sẽ tham khảo t
ngày này.
Mấy ông không biết tôi đang nói gì. Tôi
đang gửi một đống link lên
à.
Tôi gửi lại lưu bài mà bài tập mà
lộ trình theo từng ngày từng chút đề
ớn nh
này ấ bị T
x
Ok.
Đấy để tiết kiệm token hệ không nhiều
lắm sẽ tế và làm
5ă này,
ngày 6 này.
đang hơi làm phụ công một tí. Đáng lẽ có
thể dùng AI để làm được cái vụ này nhưng
mà thôi nghĩ là ừ
đôi khi đợi AI làm hơi lâu kiểu đấy
nhược điểm của AI đó là kiểu ngồi AI nó
vẫn nó chỉ gọi là
mình đỡ thủ công thôi chứ thực ra làm
cũng hơi lâu thật.
Tôi đang copy link ở trong a một đồng
link ở trong Discord. Mấy ông vào server
Discord ông sẽ hiểu tôi đang làm gì.
ở cái màn hình khác
8 này
ở trong cái trade chia sẻ
đây có chín page này kêu ở 100 ngày
phỏng vấn
thứ nhưng mà thực ra mình có ch 9 này
hay người ta không nghĩ ra được đề nào
nữa mà người ta sợ bị mất đề không biết
được
cứ giải trước để hạ tính ok
ừ
xem
đây đầu tiên là tôi sẽ thử giải đề này
nhá. Hôm đấy tôi có bình luận
à đâu đề này hôm đấy giải rồi. Hôm đấy
giải đề này rồi. Thôi ông ông em có góp
ý rồi.
Ok. Thội nhớ mang máng thôi. Thội không
nhớ hết đâu. Như sao mình sẽ
làm đề ngày hai đi
hoặc là đề khác. Nếu chỉ upload một hình
để làm
avatar thì công việc khá nhẹ. Nếu nâng
độ khó lên thì khả năng án nâng đó lên.
Đượ đỡ tí. Mình có ngày một là như này
đúng không? Mình sẽ có thêm một
à
cái nữa là
đề nữa là
upload
thiếu
tá
nếu chỉ
Đây.
Đấy,
tôi có một đề nữa. Nếu chỉ upload một
file hình để làm avatar
thì công việc khá nhẹ nếu nâng độ khó
lên là một video
một file video mới khá nặng thì sao?
Và
nếu user
đây nếu user
upl
nặng 10 GB
vào hệ thống
backend của bạn xử lý xa để không bị sập
s đấy.
Đề
đề này từ à kênh TikTok
xem lại cái đề này phát
này nhìn
đây. Và nếu a
đây
và à sau đó
1000 user cùng mở video vừa up
đấy
có hai
Thậm nếu chỉ upload bằng cái gì đó
không hiểu đề chưa nhỉ? Nếu mà update
một video nặng 10 GB vào hệ thống anh em
xử lý sao để không bị sập và sau đó là
1000 user cùng mở video đó thì mở video
đó
đấy thì sẽ xử lý sao đấy
đề na ná như này tôi sẽ sửa lại cái bộ
đề
kèm Mà
gọi như này nhở
tôi sẽ dá
đấy. Và
giải đi
đời giải
ui dùng cái này nó tự động gợi ý không
được rồi. Tôi sẽ tắt tắt gợi ý thôi
không
lỗi hết thiên cơ. Xem nào.
Anh biết AI template không? Lâu rồi
không thấy anh live. Anh khỏe không? Anh
đang ghim họng em ạ. Có mỗi con bò là
ghép đục [tiếng cười]
gì nhỉ?
Đợi tí tôi tớ phải tắt cái quả gợi ý của
AI đi đã.
Lộ hết thiên cơ.
Nhìn lại
táp đây
à
file
đây. Ok.
Đấy. Mất ý. Ok. Rồi
đấy. Xong rồi đấy. Ừ.
Ơ.
Ng đ
t ch đ nh đ đ đúng màả
lại cho đây
lắ đâu Đấy. Thôi
có vẻ không gợi ý nữa rồi. Ok. Ư
nó vẫn gợi ý thật ạ. Khổ không nhỉ?
Cài đặt trong setting của chính nó đấy.
Cơ ghi vào file NV á.
À anh hiểu em anh hiểu em cũng là một
cách
ok
đây đúng không?
Đấy
nó vẫn gợi ý mà anh để mặc định gợi ý
hết
hơi thảo mai nữa.
Sao từ này là cái gì nhỉ? Upload load đi
ch MD.
Thực ra mình chưa kết này được mà.
Đấy. Thế là xong.
Không đọc được đây file nào thì sẽ không
gợi ý nữa.
Đấy. Gợi ý mắt hả? Không tự gì kì
em nhớ co cơ tắt góc phải cần đây à đây
đây đây
công chỉnh trong kia trưởng
rồi
lời giả
Ừ. Thực tế anh chưa nghĩ được đâu. Có
khi câu giờ mình ngồi nghĩ thêm đấy vì
anh chưa làm file theo video bao giờ.
Anh làm à upload file nặng có nhưng mà
thấy xử lý file theo kiểu là đọc file
Excel ấy ưng xử lý dần dần dần lưu vào.
Còn à cái này nên như nào anh hướng đến
hướng đến thì sẽ là sử dụng à F3 để mà
đẩy dữ liệu lên.
Đấy anh cứ trả lời đã sai thì mình dùng
anh sửa sau. Mình cứ giả sử đây phỏng
vấn thật đi đúng không? Mấy ông đọc đề
này cũng thể ngồi
ngồi giải của tôi nhá. Coi như là tôi
bảo tôi không làm nhiều về hệ thống và
đặc biệt là những cái đề như này có khi
là gọi như này
đi làm thực tế là ít động phải. Đ nói
thẳng như thế
có đúng chuyên ngành mình đâu động thẳng
qu
ừ đấy thì ý anh thấy mình phỏng vấn đôi
khi là nó sẽ dính vào những câu mà mình
đúng là mình không gặp mà thì mình chỉ
nói ý tưởng của mình xong rồi các thứ
thôi đúng không?
Đầu tiên là video nặng 10 GB. Anh nghĩ
là
với
thì
sẽ
này upload dần lên
F3 chẳng hạn Amazon đúng không?
Đấy.
Còn à khi mà video đó thì
truyền về đây anh đang nói theo kiểu gọi
là
xem phim chẳng hạn đúng không? Rõ ràng
là nó sẽ truyền dạng
stream về thay vì toàn bộ.
Đấy. Anh vẫn nhớ cái cách làm. Cách làm
tương tự
cách làm đấy là học anh nhớ là hồi trước
là có đọc qua cái bài cái nguyên lý hoạt
động của [khịt mũi] IDM. Các bạn biết
IDM không? Hình như mình có một video
ngồi nói qua về đây. Nghĩa là bản chất
là video đấy sẽ được cắt nhỏ ra và hỗ
trợ là kiểu truyền lên cái dạng
truyền ra truyền lên cái dạng là
kiểu dạng là truyền lên kiểu start này
bằng chấm chấm chấm này và
à param này
param chuyển đến start chấm chấm chấm và
N bằng chấm chấm chấm kiểu nha. Để lấy
để lấy đây x đi dễ.
Đây Y y đi đấy để lấy cái từng từng từng
màu từng màu một. Đấy kiểu thế xong rồi
thì sẽ ở ở font về mặt giao diện ở giao
diện
sẽ nối lại với nhau sau. Còn back end
thì sẽ trả về kiểu thế và nó còn rất phù
hợp với việc là à
với làm chưởng như này nhá rất phù hợp
việc là về sau có thể tải continue tải
tiếp được cái file
sẽ vào tạ hỗ trợ được tải tiếp
file ví dụ là kiểu nếu mà file của em
chỉ có một cục thôi thì khi em đang tải
nội trường mà bị lỗi là em chỉ có thể là
bắt người dùng là tải lại cả cục đấy.
Còn nếu mà mà file của em chia nhỏ như
này thì khi mà em đang tải mà bị lỗi nửa
chừng đúng không ạ? Thì thì người ta vẫn
phải continue từ cái đoạn đoạn kia đoạn
nửa nửa đấy đúng không?
Tạo database để lưu trung gian. Ừ cái
database thì không nói, cái cách để mà
lấy ra được cái file này không nói. Ờ
cái quan trọng là mình sẽ lo dần kiểu nó
ra như nào thôi. Nên nói ý tưởng như thế
này. Đấy và 1000 user cùng mở thì đấy
nếu mà chơ nhỏ ra thế thì một cánh nặng
nó bị giảm đi này. Đấy, thậm chí là
video hay là các file ở trên a video hay
file ở trên Google Drive
là dạng peer to peer. Nhớ thế, nhớ thế
thôi nhá. Không chắc lắm đâu nhá.
Tức là sao? Nghĩa là kiểu hồi trước hồi
trước là chính lớp anh anh tự cảm thấy
phát hiện ra điều đấy vì chính lớp anh
dạy hồi chưa anh tải file lên nhá.
[khịt mũi]
À
một bạn
dùng trong máy local mạng lan của
không phải mạng lan nó nó dùng từ như
nào đã khá là bạn ấy dùng máy của trường
đã tải được cái file của anh rồi thì tất
cả các bạn kia cũng sẽ dễ tải mất không
load nó nhanh hơn ý kiểu load được cái
file kia rồi đấy nên là có vẻ tải file
đấy từ chính máy của bạn kia nhanh hơn
này nhưng mà mỗi tội Và khi anh đăng lên
cái bản chỉnh sửa
thì gove nó không cập nhật luôn. Đấy
nó giống như kích lại ấ nhưng thực ra an
nghĩ là cái cách nó là kiểu P2P kiểu
này. Thế nên là các bạn thể phải mở ẩn
danh mà toạn để mà lấy được cái file
mới.
thì tôi từng thấy
à một người trong mạng là
tài đồ
những người kia
phải
rất nhanh nhưng mà khi thay đổi
origin
thì cách
file cũ phải ẩn danh
để đoạn file mới
đấy kiểu thế tả lại trang vẫn file cũ
nhá phải kể cả con shift 5 luôn đấy phải
mở hẳn danh giống như kiểu dùng IP khác
ấy kiểu phải thế
anh đoán thấy nhá không biết
Tôi nghĩ có thể thao vào
cách đó.
Ok. Giờ tôi sẽ đầu tiên là trông có vẻ
xong rồi đúng không? Đấy tôi sẽ dùng chữ
EI để phan điện.
Tôi mới tạo xong file
à tôi mới làm xong đề này
chân vào chữa cho tôi
cái file anh phải xem lại file agent cái
thứ này
mục tiêu của file agent này là
Đ cho cái ảnh sẽ không dễ
Có vẻ cái file Agent này không khớp lắm
so V cái mục tiêu của tôi
à
và sửa lại file agent.
Đúng rồi, đúng rồi. Đấy, đánh lại sửa
lại
được chưa? Và me
sao cho phù hợp?
Vì tôi không dùng để giải đề mà dùng để
chữa
lại hẳn 2 đi ra xa 2 mỗi khi bạn tiền
chúng ta để xa 2
hỏi lại tôi để xác nhận thay đổi hai
file kia
đã rồi mới chấm
nên có phản biện
à đề xuất
cũng như
chỉ ra ưu nhường
chấm chấm chấm tức là hình để chấm chấm
chấm thường anh nên hạn chế chấm chấm
chấm
2 đi làm quả đợi lâu đấy
Tội tôi tí.
Hình như là tôi
trả tiền
cái trả trước.
thanh toán trả trước
rồi.
Thời tí
không nhớ không làm luôn quên ấ
anh ơi. Ok em ơi.
Rồi dùng để theo hướng chữa nào. Chữa
bài phản biện không giải ngay. Ok luôn.
Tranh thủ lúc đấy lưu thêm cái đề nữa.
Có thêm một đề nữa đ không ạ?
Nhưng mà hôm nay thì chắc là day one chỉ
thôi. Tôi sẽ tạo day two đi. Ngày hai
là mình sẽ có cái đề là
sắp xếp lịch. Sắp xếp lịch tiếng Anh là
gì?
Chúng ta sắp xếp lịch và phân công. Tôi
sẽ dùng à chat GPT để gợi ý. à gợi ý
tên đề
à tên tiếng Anh chuyên ngành
ngắn gọn cho tôi với cái đề này
theo dạng SL
scaling
scaluling
Ok tí luôn
dễ hiểu đấy. Đó sẽ có đây này.
À
nghĩ cho tôi bộ đề
theo
à để phù hợp với
học system design. Thực tế là các bạn
nên dùng prom ý. Kiểu các bạn
cá nhân tôi không thích việc nói một lúc
kiểu cả nửa Anh nửa Việt nhưng mà khi mà
các bạn prom nếu có thể thì các bạn nên
thuần một là thuần tiếng Anh càng tốt,
hai là bởi vì đôi khi mình quen từ tiếng
Việt hơn thì mình sẽ mô tả tiếng Việt nó
rõ ràng hơn đúng không? Đấy nhưng có
những từ khóa chức ngành các bạn vẫn nên
dùng tiếng Anh đấy thế nên là tôi sẽ
thường hay kiểu ví dụ là tôi đang dùng
chat bảo là nghị cho tôi bộ đề phù hợp
với cái tập toán sắp xếp lực và phân
công đúng không để học system design đấy
cho senior đấy đấy
thưởng tạo project riêng trên chat ppt
web sau nó ra đề ngẫu nhiên cho em hàng
ngày luôn đúng tại anh có sẵn mấy cái bộ
đề này anh muốn làm trước thôi Chứ về
sau tự mình soạn ra bộ đề ngẫu nhiên các
thứ được mà.
Rồi xem nào. Ồ ok. Thôi thì trong này có
căn cái file này tôi sẽ cứ làm luôn.
Ok hết luôn được không sao. Còn nhiều
token
này tặc thử.
Hệ thống sắp xếp lịch
t khám
chốt một cái thôi
kèm bộ đề chi tiết.
À rồi chi tiết không
đ ngắn gọn.
Bộ đây chống dài quá.
xem
ngắn gọn hơn nữa
như đi phỏng vấn
Tốn token quá sót tiền trên kia phi mà
đâu chết đâu miễn phí. Notebook LM á hay
là TV á?
Không em không biết được là công ty cấp
cho anh tài khoản đây. Cloud
premium
cả ngày hôm nay dùng có được 13% mà hôm
qua vừa bị resch đấy. Càng ngày hôm nay
dùng được có thứ
coi ai tranh thủ bào em ạ. Nãy anh không
dùng c lau chứ.
Đây đây là sẽ trình ngắn gọn này thiết
kế hệ thống sắp xếp lịch và phân công
nhân sự cho nhiều ca làm nhiều địa điểm
có dòng bố về kỹ năng nói nhỉ giới hạn
giờ làng và tránh xưng đổi lịch đấy
đấy từ khóa sẽ là đây
Cửa khóa
đấy. Data module
sceduling
organism đấy. Conf detection manual
override notification audit lock
concurrencyity.
Đấy ok luôn.
Đấy
xịn không ạ?
Tôi trông thấy xịn.
M 4/10 a
thầy kiếm mấy để ở đâu vậy á? Anh có
chat ở trên Discord đấy.
Anh gửi lại link Discord cho các bạn
nha.
Invite
to server. Đấy.
Invite to channel luôn cho móng.
Đấy. Thay cái link link tin kia đi. Ok.
Ờ bạn chấm và sửa vào luôn file
không sửa phần đời giải tài là
D này đó.
Tôi tự tin là tôi làm trông cũng chuẩn
chỉ phết đấy chứ
đúng không ạ? Nếu ông thấy cũng không
nỗi đúng không?
Cái này hôm trước làm rồi. Xóa đi.
Không xóa không xóa. Tôi sẽ tạo cái
repo ở trên GitHub cho mấy ông
ngồi làm qua cùng nha.
Anh thử tương tự với Chtity kết quả sẽ
tốt hơn. Codex cũng là Charity mà ông
bình tôi à?
Ông bình tôi đúng không?
Con này không phải là của chat là gì hả?
Đ con này cũng là cho DTI thôi. Cùng một
con cùng một con model mà
chưa chắc là cùng model đồ cơ. Nghĩa là
con này thậm chí xịn hơn.
Đầu sáng đ giả
liên tục hoàn cay nhờ 4 ch 10 4/10
đúng comp không sao không sao mình xem
trong đi đúng hướng
không xử lý giống avatar window file lớn
là object storage và khi xem không tải
ngên về một lần vẫn thiếu nhiều cốt lõi
Không sập của dòng thì đúng nhất trong
bài là dùng S3 và stream cho từng đoạn
nhưng trong vấn đề dần lên và stream về
là chưa đủ còn nói backend
nó nằm trên dat của
line upload cơ chế gì video được xử lý
sau render à sau upload ra sau
đúng rồi dùng cdn nhỉ quyết mất nhỉ quết
mất cdn qu đây nên định chưa chắc đúng
hiện tượng loát nhanh trong c đến từ
cách xem
chúng cách của ứng dụng hoặc có chế cách
cho
nên tránh kết luận về p2p nếu không có
bằng chứng kiểm đúng biết không nên xử
lý nào tên 3 các thứ thứ nó thời
streaming các thầ các thứ nhận ra cách
có ảnh hưởng đến khi mở video
thiếu hoặc sai xin lỗi b không nên nhận
trực tiếp các thứ thứ
liên quan đến panage memory time out
connection low và tra khó đúng đúng chel
m
đây là ý quan trọng nhất cho phần upload
ù tôi còn chưa biết cái preside này tôi
có nghe rồi này chưa biết rõ này cái này
cũng chưa biết này được chưa có bớt bước
thì lưu metadata thôi thôi ừ thực ra là
tôi lại báo hạn chế nhắc đến phần đề
databas
Nhưng mà thôi không sao cứ đề cập cũng
được thì ý tôi là việc lư bay rồi thấy
nó quá bình thường nó chưa phải là một
cái gì kểu phải toán xử lý để ở đây cả
nhưng mà thôi mình đang nói về kiểu flow
từng bước từng bước thì cái này có càng
tốt chưa có ass processing sau khi Đúng
rồi cái này gần đây tôi mới làm kiểu
mình sẽ hiển thị ra cho người dùng là
kiểu
đang gì lý dần dần từ đâu đến đâu tránh
việc Và phải dùng
we phải đợi các thứ thứ ấ như nào đang
loading ling dần vân vân dạn đúng không?
Đấy chưa có CDN và m user cùng xem tất
cả đọc từ back end hoặc historic thì
khóa tải x cao ok ý gần đúng nhưng cách
chuẩn hơn là từ range header hoặc stream
qua ồ cũng không biết cái này luôn
đây này bây giờ mới một trong những cái
hay này ví dụ vừa rồi tôi còn những cái
tôi bảo tôi không biết đúng không? Đấy
tôi sẽ a
ghi những cái từ khóa
gọi là [khịt mũi]
tôi sẽ ghi lại những cái từ khóa mà tôi
không biết và một cái file nào đó để mà
về sau nó sẽ về sau mình tự nghĩ là đề
mà đúng không? sẽ dùng để kiểu hoặc là
không đơn giản không cần nghĩ đề giống
như kiểu ông bảo đẩy lên nút búc lm ấy
thì nó sẽ có cơ chế là hỏi lại mình cái
ý nghĩa của từng cái là gì, mục tiêu của
từng cái là gì chạy được. Đế là tôi sẽ
bổ sung mặt đi.
H tại sao lại có HS ở đây này.
Anh thử P này vào xem là chấm bao nhiêu.
Đạo database để lưu trung gian chỉ chừa
pover.
Cái tin nhắn của em bị dài quá rồi bị
cắt mất rồi.
Hả? Anh sẽ đẩy cái a viipo này lên giub
để cho các bạn tự tự ngồi làm. Không sao
không sao. Tí anh đẩy lên bây giờ phải.
Tí em tự à
tự test
tốt nhất đúng không? À tôi nghĩ là nên
bổ sung thêm một phần.
Tôi phải rút cái này vào để mẹ nhấc này
tua.
Keyw á.
À không không anh không nghĩ được không
sao mình chấm có thể sai không quan
trọng mình quan trọng là nó trả lời cho
mình nghe phẩng biện có vẻ hợp lý để
mình học hỏi thêm đúng không sao
bổ sung phần keyword
để tôi lưu lại sau mỗi bài
tôi biết tôi cầm
khôn lại những cái Đó về sau sẽ có một
command.
Hiện tại đang có command a
command nào nhỉ? Command tạo D đúng
không? Tất nhiên cái màn hình của tôi bị
bé lại nhỉ.
à
tạo một command tử
keyword
phá một command để chấm dướp
mắt là chợ
choch
và phất này thôi.
Hi lại t để hiểu rõ con.
Ui x2
video này dài phết đấy.
Livestream cũng gần 2 tiếng rồi.
Đây dùng
cl
có điều kiện dùng coneix bẹt nhè như này
được.
Màn hình tự nhiên bé đi để tôi cho màn
hình to lên cho mấy dễ nhìn nhá. Tôi vừa
rút một cái màn hình ra bị nhấp nháy.
Thường là tôi để màn hình này cỡ cỡ này
đấy.
Đấy đâu nhìn thấy đỡ hơn đúng không? chữ
đỡ hơn
không giản thay
form cục bộ chứ vừa nãy vừa nói xong chỉ
cho project này xong
À có thêm bộ
Xin chào em. Ơ ông này ông này nói luôn
tiếng Anh này. Hello A nên ra là nó
không dịch. Bình thường mấy ông khác nói
tiếng Việt xong rồi nó cứ dịch linh
tinh.
Làm nốt cái này xong
không chắc nghỉ rồi làm nốt này được rồi
đâ sẽ chái trong
Ok.
Ok. chỉnh sửa luôn thừ
ấp ben hết vào.
Anh quên nguyên tắc cơ bản về backup rồi
hả? Backup cái gì?
Back up cái gì? Mà sao
không? A luôn đẩy luôn đẩy code lên á.
Nhìn không nên mình lấy từ đâu
tôi sẽ cung cấp
và
nó không phải mỗi keyword của
bài mà thậm chí từ chín bài giải
của bạn
Tôi cũng sẽ điến lại những từ đó
sau ôn lại.
Nếu mà tôi gửi cái bài đề này của tôi
lên git thì mấy ông sẽ xem mất cái bài à
tôi trả lời nhỉ.
Thậng chĩ cả bài tôi chấm nữa mà trong
khi đó các bạn th chỉ quan tâm đề thôi
không nên lắm. Tôi mình sẽ phải sửa lại
cấu trúc tí vì tôi đẩy
à project này
lên h để mọi người cùng thử
chữa ra trong đời
đấy.
Nó sẽ là SD
là
keyword
cũng được.
Tốt bình luận một tí mà anh em khả ha ha
nhiều thế nhạy cảm hết. T bình luận vào
trong bài của bộ công an nói việc kéo
tuyển chọn là phục vụ cho cục công nghệ
cộng cục công nghệ thông tin của bộ công
an mà yêu cầu đúng kiểu dạng đủ kiểu
tuyển của công an không không lắm tư bản
gốc vào trong đồng thời copy vào ch
ba solution review keyword rõ nhệp file
luôn. Ok. Cái này b này sẽ
để về sau sẽ ôn lại các từ khóa đến
mạng. Nghĩa là các mấy ông không phải
ngồi giải đề xong là xong đúng không?
Tôi đang tạo thêm cái command là để mà
lưu lại các từ khóa nhá. Xong rồi về sau
sẽ tạo một command nữa là tạo bộ đề dựa
trên các từ khóa đấy hoặc là
bộ đề đây không cần nhất bộ đề như này
đâu mà là bộ trắc nghiệm ấy nó giống cái
nút bú LM ấy là tạo ra bản quýt là c
trắc nghiệm để mà mấy ông ôn lại cái này
chứ chứ bộ đề ông giải xong mà không đọp
lại gì trong đầu kiểu ngồi đọc cách chữa
xong ông lại quên đi bằng 0 đúng không
sau chống lên cái phí bạnh ở đâu
Đ ch m M.
Ồ Ok.
Tí tôi lười cực tí tôi sẽ bảo ai ngồi à
tự tạo xong tự mướt lên mà thôi rồi đấy
tự tạo trong lúc đang đợi
mình sẽ tạo
create new đi
là
system design
T không
ok
trong này đã có những cái pha rồi.
Ch thế này chung về ổn này
ok làm luôn
bây giờ của cái này hiển thị ra cái này
à chắc mọi khi tắt cái này đi hiển thị
ra cái này cho nó hay phết
H
Ù nhìn thịtach bài cũ này các thứ thứ
tôi quên mất cái này chuẩn phải tạo sub
agent để ngồi làm song song
thôi cũng dài thôi thôi xong cái này tôi
sẽ commit rồi đẩy lên cho mấy ông à còn
mấy ông thì bây giờ có thể một là hỏi
thêm gì hai là thôi chắc là tôi sẽ tạm
tắt livestream đã tôi sẽ đẩy cái này lên
cho mấy ông sau nhá ok xin chào mấy nhá.
Hai tiếng sợ thật.
Mai mai chắc chắn sẽ ngắn hơn. Ok. Chào
mấy ông nhá. Bé ông nghỉ nhá. Ồ. Ok.